okay let's go ahead and get started this
is very impressive turnout I know that
all of Travis's fellow fellows are here
and many others number of faculty and
this is a relatively rare event but
important event for the program and
hopefully will become more frequent over
the years but a PhD dissertation defense
I think what this is about the how many
alumni do we have in PhD about 12 I
think or okay so maybe we'll be the
lucky 13 anyways probably everyone in
the room knows Travis who has been here
for some time as most PhD students are
so he's been funded by our National
Library medicine training grant and he
is defending his PhD dissertation so as
I explained wrongly like a couple times
in the past few months but in a defense
he we do the public presentation the
audience asked questions the audience is
dismissed the committee stays behind ask
further questions then the candidate is
dismissed and the committee makes their
determination of passing the defense not
necessarily the degree the it still
needs to be written up and approved and
so forth although i think his name will
probably appear in the graduation book
that's distributed this week but as the
book says just because you're in the
book doesn't mean you have the degree so
okay probably more than you want to know
anyway some Travis came to us from
Arkansas he had a bachelor's degree in
computer science from the University of
Central Arkansas and also an MBA from
the University of Arkansas he's done a
lot of research work since he's been
here and he's going to tell us about it
today while he's been here he's also
worked on some projects at the Portland
VA which I see several VA folks here
today and
also did which others of you in the
training grant have done and should
consider doing if you have the
opportunity the summer rotation at the
lister hill center at NLM and he's also
volunteering as an as an advocate for
the National Alliance on Mental Illness
so he's going to give us a talk on his
dissertation work I really appreciate
everyone showing up today and listening
to me present my dissertation today I'm
presenting my work in the area of
terminology development text mining and
data mining through applications of
techniques in these areas I present
approach to address unstructured free
text to the growing problem of data
overload so much of my interest is in
building biomedical software
applications specifically to support
clinicians and researchers workflow and
more specifically to support clinical
decision applications where acceptance
and reliance on the suggestions that the
systems provide will be determined
ultimately be determined by their
respective accuracy it's difficult to
really project the future of biomedical
software but in order to achieve this
accuracy that's going to be needed it's
a safe to assume that it will need to be
supported by a robust knowledge base and
these knowledge bases have the
opportunity to be the bridge between
unstructured data and structured data so
with that presenting my research in the
medical sub domain of PTSD for which I
will provide a quick background and also
a background on various terminology
systems and structures that I explored
in this research also present a
conceptual overview of my project which
consists of the development of the
terminology framework and specifically
its implementation to support several
text mining pipelines for concept
recognition
and then using the output from these
pipelines I use that to support a
cluster analysis and an association rule
mining use case and then finally closed
with some opportunities that I come
across to continue this work so PTSD or
post-traumatic stress disorder is an
anxiety disorder that is triggered by a
traumatic event such as military combat
natural disasters and various types of
assaults the list of potential symptoms
is large but generally includes varying
degrees of depression flashbacks
aggressiveness and a functional
impairment so much of my dissertation as
bill said was developed in coordination
with the Department of Veteran Affairs
health care system which mostly has a
population explodes exposed to high
incidence of traumatic events the
prevalence studies vary greatly but for
the VA it's estimated that somewhere
around thirty percent of veterans
experience some form of the disorder
compared to about seven to eight percent
of the general US population this high
prevalence along with insufficient
screening as well as poor symptoms that
can show up much later after the trauma
has occurred and other factors
contribute to the current health care
system both at the VA and within
community health care settings not
equipped to adequately cope with this
disorder however one way to assist
clinicians and researchers is the
development of health information
systems tools and projects that are
still needed a key resource to support
these tools and projects are knowledge
bases or vocabularies that are shown
here and they're built in several
formats and with varying degrees of
coverage granularity and processing
ability so simply a terminology consists
of
collection of terms words and phrases
representing and describing a system of
concepts within a domain so numerous
formats such as those displayed along
the slide they've been used very
successfully in in current to support a
really a broad range of applications but
as shown along the spectrum the cost of
time and money increased proportionately
with the semantic processing capability
of each complex structure so several
several medical and life science
terminologies that are put in use today
reside at multiple points along the
spectrum so my terminology fits
somewhere here just passed a taxonomy
but short of a full-blown ontology the
PTSD terminology is referred to in it
SAT with its acronym PTSD oh and my
throughout this presentation this is
simply a persistent Uniform Resource
locator simply a naming classification
that allows this terminology terminology
to be shared as well as the concepts
that contains and added added context so
the reason of the naming for PTSD o
stands for posttraumatic stress stress
stress disorder ontology as future
implementations will be to extend this
terminology into a net on ontology for
supporting semantic web applications so
a general role in order to apply a a an
efficient cost-benefit ratio is to only
build a structure with enough semantic
processing capability in order to
support its intended application
so many existing terminologies today
have limited coverage and missing
information with respects to PTSD
concepts and their meaning the
subjective nature of trauma is barrier
to fully understanding the disorder but
a clear opportunity is improving
knowledge and extraction of clinical
narratives such as this this narrative
is from a case report and it's obviously
rich and needed PTSD terms so in the pre
PTSD terminology world existing
terminologies did a really good job a
good job of recognizing tokens although
there is room for improvement in this
text processed with C takes NOP natural
language processing pipeline supported
by an existing publicly available
terminology the identified treatments
are highlighted in blue the symptoms
that are identified are highlighted in
green the red displays false positives
which are pervasive in any terminology
with a really broad coverage circled and
orange shows the domain related concepts
that are missed by the system so one
caveat it's not just important to be
able to extract or identify these
concepts but also to link them to an
established terminology standard as well
this need for improved coverage is the
motivation behind the research that I'm
presenting today which can be summarized
in this conceptual model so the goal as
stated here is to identify PTSD symptoms
and treatment concepts for mining
applications this is achieved through
synthesis of terminologies in order to
improve the text mining and the first
aim terminology is collected by manually
acquiring concepts from existing
resources
there is also a knowledge acquisition
that's collected by a semi automated
process so it is it's i hypothesize that
the iterative semi-automated knowledge
acquisition this approach will will
determine when sufficient coverage is
met in order to satisfy stakeholder
needs the collection is stored in
xml-based format easily to convertible
to support various types of text mining
pipelines in aim to it is validated by
coverage accuracy from recall and
precision measurements on to gold
standards that are created specifically
the focus of aim to is named entity
recognition this is enhanced by a
dictionary based look up for concept
recognition in this automated process
any concepts or terms that not in
identified because they are missing they
are added to the terminology and there
is a built-in confirmation loop at each
tax at each task by domain experts the
hypothesis is that the accuracy of the
newly developed terminology will be
significantly higher than coverage of
other evaluated resources with the text
processing pipelines and then finally
for aim three the table of extractions
that are collected are applied to a data
mining use case the clusters formed are
predicted to produce concepts that group
uniformly with diagnostic criteria
so a hybrid of methodologies are drawn
from from requirements gathering and
terminology development to implement a
structured process while acquiring
feedback during construction so the
first method listed here is a popular
method commonly referred to as ontology
development 101 simply the steps are
determining the scope enumerated the
terms linking them to existing resources
and defining the hierarchical structure
and this these steps fit into the
four-stage engineering model that's
shown here and described by the second
methodology meth ontology the steps are
simply the specification keeps the
system in scope throughout the project
conceptualization structures don't want
to film a domain knowledge form of
formalization converts it into
computable models and before
implementing the terminology into a
computational language that must be
maintained and constantly reevaluated
also the SKR methods this is the
semantic knowledge representation group
at the National Library of Medicine they
implement a version of this four stage
engineering for collecting knowledge to
support a PubMed visualization
application called somatic medula
somatic Medlen as bill saying I had the
opportunity to actually spend two
rotations working with this group and
learning the details of this application
and specifically the steps that they
applied to acquire their knowledge I was
able to use those methods directly into
my work so also implemented is a hybrid
of techniques for entity identification
which includes both dictionary based and
rule-based and then finally because of
all the moving parts to the project
agile techniques were implemented for
both software development as well as
project management general idea behind
agile is to identify problems address
them and then move on to the next issue
really important for applying some sort
of methodology to the chaos and the mini
Moo
pieces to my project and keep it moving
forward so before going on I think it's
important to take a few seconds just to
highlight some of the most salient needs
that this research was directed to
address so it's known about the large
amount of data that is stored in
narrative text especially for mental
mental health patient records where a
majority of the details of are
completely stored in subjective
subjective type texts and this makes the
automation of extracting this
information particularly challenging
which is why I focus this research from
the ground up where first I focused on
building the terminology and then
secondly building the applications that
process these texts so without proper
use of the terminology it can really
become a bottleneck for achieving the
accuracy and creating innovation and
better quality assessments of these PTSD
applications um also from the
stakeholder interviewing and
requirements gathering task it was
returned that the priority need from
users was concept recognition this also
determined that the scope of the
terminology would focus explicitly on
the treatments and symptom concepts so
many of the more complex questions that
that arose from stakeholders they could
only be answered once this accurate
concept recognition was achieved some of
the questions attained to future
information extraction such as
evaluating how well symptoms treat
specific sorry symptoms treat specific
symptoms as well as analyzing how PTSD
interacts with comorbid disorders and
ultimately for a way to determine
patient resiliency but however the
answers could be in the free text but
concept recognition is a prerequisite so
as I was consulting with the
stakeholders and domain experts I built
a prototype from the resources that were
listed here some of required a manual
linguistic analysis to acquire terms
this prototype framework also provided a
visual resource to improve interviews by
guiding user discussions with some of
the stakeholders listed here
conversations were much more mutually
beneficial stakeholders also provided
input to the validity of the concepts
whether any were missing and each was a
given opportunity to make any changes to
the concepts that were required so next
an element of automation is incorporated
all available electronic documents
needed for domain terminology was
processed with a text mining pipeline
supported by the in development PTSD
terminology framework so what does this
figure showing when a term is not
identified the pts do is researched to
determine whether it exists in the
terminology when in determine when it's
determine the identify term is not in
the terminology reputable terminologies
and ontology czar referenced before
adding it into the terminology then the
text mining pipeline is reprocessed and
its reevaluate reevaluated to see if it
is identified again so as the
development was iterative the updated
prototype was presented to fall in
follow ups interview sessions with the
stakeholders and this allowed for an
ongoing confirmation loop to be
established for continuous verification
of concepts within the terminology
so to provide a grill quick picture of
how the terminology is modeled some of
the upper-level classes for symptoms are
shown here on the left symptoms are
grouped in coordination with their
associated dsm category I will provide a
good background on this DSM and these
symptoms a little bit later as i'm using
the dsm as a basis for my cluster
analysis on the right our treatment
concepts these are groups in categories
that are designated by the joint Veteran
Affairs Department of Defense clinical
management guidelines for PTSD so each
of these concepts contain more granular
concepts that just specifically describe
each category and then each of those
contain even more granular terms such as
synonyms abbreviations and acronyms so a
large percentage of this work for this
research work in task related to
acquiring the terms to build this
terminology and although terminology
structure is never really finished
because of constant changes new research
and new findings a stopping point for
this research is based upon reaching
reasonable levels of saturation which is
represented here in this saturation
curve so any electronic corpus can be
mined with this semi automated knowledge
acquisition technique for example pubmed
available abstracts using haynes
clinical queries filters search with a
narrow scope that returned about 2,000
pretty salient abstracts in this figure
is a saturation curve where a total of
three hundred sixty three concepts were
obtained from this corpus and saturation
was reached at around 700 documents so
for the last about 75 documents or so
zero new concepts were obtained
so as the pts do terminology was being
built I sought to answer whether
sufficient concepts could be acquired
from available resources so to
investigate this term overlap in turn
reuse for explored as well as concept
overlap that's shown in the slide the
top bar displays and identified 356
concepts that were necessary to describe
the PTSD symptomatology of those 240
were found in existing resources so some
of those that were found worthy listed
here 116 such as those listed new
concepts here were created new meaning
they were not found in an existing
resource or not found used in the
correct context or with the correct
meaning so of the 240 that were found
there is an overlap of about 70 2.5% and
what this means is that these concepts
exist and two or more resources but
they're not linked by an external
reference so this highlights a lack of
term reuse that needs more attention in
the development community the term reuse
can reduce engineering costs and some
more support semantic interoperability
among different types of data sets and
applications this overlap was also shows
are seen in symptoms at close to
eighty-five percent so to close up aim
one this large amount of overlapping
terms with minimal reuse in comparison
goes against the purpose of terminology
standardization interoperability and
sharing as a part of this research
development was to include these
external references whenever available a
great it was found that a great amount
of time went into searching for their
availability and this adds considerable
amount of time to an already
time-consuming process so this creates
an opportune
to streamline this process and the
development community would benefit
greatly from this so the primary go of
aim to was to improve named entity
recognition which is a subtask of
information extraction and natural
language processing the aim of in a name
to digg recognition is to seek and
locate and classify elements into of
text into predefined categories which
for this research was treatment and
symptoms so there are several low level
natural language processing tasks such
as tokenizing tagging chunking
normalizing and parsing and each of
these must be completed before any of
these higher level tasks are completed
to include name digiti recognition named
entry recognition is typically evaluated
by precision and recall measures as well
as a harmonic harmonic meaning of the
two which is the F measure however these
are calculated in the context of natural
language processing which recall and
precision are relatively straightforward
when tasks are focused at the document
level however when we're focusing on
tokens such as in this research boundary
errors are very common so for instance
this group of terms aggressive outburst
as one single concept outburst is found
however aggressive is missed so in
traditional accuracy scoring this would
count as both the false positive and
false negative in traditionally finding
nothing would have produced a better
metric so in to overcome this in main
entity recognition of elation left
boundary right boundary and partial
matches are calculated for partial
credit
for aim to evaluation of symptom and
treatment terminology to go standards
were created from the corporate used for
automated knowledge acquisition 10% was
set aside for testing which left 122
pubmed case reports also 82
psychotherapeutic transcripts were
annotated for evaluation for goat
standard creation overall entertainer
inner annotator agreement for pubmed
case reports was between eighty and
ninety percent and for the therapy
transcripts it was between 68 and
eighty-four percent also multiple text
mining pipelines and was supported by
several terminologies against the gold
standards so for overall analysis the
two target concepts of treatment and
symptoms each on the two corporate
listed here were analyzed with 20
combinations made up of these four text
mining pipelines being supported by
these five terminologies and so for each
combination what was identified was
exact matches left boundary matches
right boundary and partial matching
partial matches and this created a large
amount of data points that are gathered
some of the categories false positives
are listed down here what any with any
anyone that's done natural language
processing work errors are unavoidable
but what the error analysis exhibits is
that a large quantity of the errors were
due to the lack of availability in a
terminology resource and this type of
error can be correct corrected with the
automated concept identification that I
described in the previous slide for
knowledge acquisition
so moving from this preet preet PTSD
terminology world to this wonderful
world where it now exists the focus on
improving name 2d recognition with the
support of the developed terminology
from aim one dictionary basting
dictionary based coverage increases the
identity the entities that are
identified so in this reprocessed case
report here easy fixes occur when those
concepts or terms can be inputted into
the terminology and then reprocess for
recognition so specifically identified
of concepts from the concept overlap
slide that was input are symptoms of
self-blame and trust issues as well as
stress inoculation and impact statement
that are now found so some false
positives such as depression here they
cannot be helped and technically this is
a correct concept in the domain of PTSD
however this task was directed not to
include symptoms that are obviously a
part of other mental health disorders so
and also the pipeline that processed
this text was not able to identify the
concept of self-mutilating here even
though it is in the terminology resource
some pipeline deficiencies can't be
helped so likely this one was missed
because of the hyphenation and possibly
because of the ten sending of the word
in the task of concert recognition I
sought to determine if there's variance
between the terminologies and support of
the text mining pipelines out of the 20
combinations that are evaluated this is
just one comesss combination as an
example shown in this graph it's a
fairly good representation of a general
pattern across each that is observed
this figure displays variability in
accuracy metrics of identification of
treatment concepts and the PubMed corpus
explicitly and accuracy is measured
against each of these five terminologies
so the first set of bars is from the
terminology developed in this research
it generally has a higher f-measure than
the other terminologies generally it's
precision is much higher than its Rico
next is pilots which is the PTSD
dedicated thesaurus it generally
generally has really good a really good
precision that's slightly higher than
its rico and this same sort of pattern
is mimicked with sno-med and the
National Cancer Institute at the Saurus
the last terminology the umls which is
the unified medical language system this
is a system of terminologies maintained
by the National Library of Medicine
comprehensive collection of over 100
terminologies about a million concepts
and four million name for those concepts
the universe by design typically has a
better recall than its precision often
due to word sense disambiguation
something that was improved by limiting
the types of semantic the semantic types
that were required so to wrap up into
without a doubt there's great complexity
in clinical entity identification but
what is found is the importance of a
domain specific terminology with
sufficient coverage there's enough
headaches and in working with out with
these text mining pipeline and
implementing them most are not
user-friendly and frequently the output
needs to be reformatted for use the
enhancing the terminology it can improve
the output but it is found there's a
definite need for improving text mining
pipeline usability
in aim tree and to make use of the
collection of concepts that were
extracted a cluster analysis use case is
implemented cluster analysis or
clustering is a descriptive analysis
where the task is to group a set of
objects into the same group where each
are more similar in some sense or
another to objects that are located in
the other clusters in this example
clustering is performed based upon
extracted sin symptom concepts that are
represented here in these word cloud
Custer clusters extractions from C takes
NOP pipeline supported with the umls as
a baseline is compared to extractions
that are supported with the PTSD
terminology system and this were
implemented to explore whether could
these concepts could provide insights
from the data the probability of a
membership to a cluster in this research
is computed by a concept co-occurrence
matrix the corpus that is used is the
PubMed kate pubmed abstracts
specifically the search of PTSD case
reports returned just over twelve
hundred articles with available
abstracts so a little caveat is the case
there's a roughly over a hundred
published clustering algorithms and
several were explored for this research
but the k-means clustering algorithm is
implemented where heuristic calculations
determined six clusters for both the
umls and the PTSD terminology
so in order to implement the k-means
clustering algorithm one investigation
I've performed is based upon the DSM
shown in those previous slides and this
is the diagnostic and statistical manual
of mental disorders it's the standard
for psychiatric diagnosis in the United
States for all mental health conditions
so there is a bit of controversy with
the use of the DSM for determining PTSD
much of it resides in the quantity of
diagnostic criteria that are listed here
so diagnosis requires symptoms from each
of these categories the first is a
stressor secondly intrusion or a
reappearance insistence it requires two
symptoms from negative cognitions two
symptoms from arousal category as well
as a functional impairment and the color
white in this research is color coded
for concepts that were identified in the
text mining pipeline that did not
pertain to PTSD or fit into a DSM
criteria also much of the controversy
stems from the large number of Senate
symptoms that fall within each of these
categories making this disorder overlap
with symptoms of several other mental
health disorders so based upon the
attractions from the case report corpus
I explored the uniformity of the DSM
clustering for PTSD since the reports
are of assumed patients diagnosed with
the disorder and cluster membership is
based upon co-occurrence at the document
level I would expect each cluster to
recapitulate from symptoms from each of
these dsm cried categories on so for
explanation purposes I represent each of
the concept co-occurrence makeup by
percentage in the pie charts
on the first row here is clustering
based upon the umls the next row is
clustering from the newly developed
terminology system so what is noticeable
is the clusters on the bottom include
concept co-occurrences that draw much
more uniformly from the dsm where those
on the top are much more distinct the
Yuma less on the top row also extracts
many concepts that didn't do not pertain
to PTSD and displayed here in white so
just to re-emphasize the symptom makeup
of the clustering such as in cluster 3
here where membership is determined by
the co-occurrence matrix in this heat
map of symptoms listed here each have
varying degrees of co-occurrence with
one another and a calculated probability
or likelihood of occurring in the
cluster of concepts so for example the
concept of trauma trigger which comes
from the DSM category of stressor and
the concept of fear from negative
alterations and cognitions and mood
these occur with one another much more
in frequently in these case reports than
the other symptoms and thus are
calculated to be members of the same
cluster so just to go review the slide
one more time the pattern of concepts
with a domain-specific ontology our
terminology replicated the dsm fairly
well now it's important to point out
that this analysis doesn't say that one
supportive terminology is better than
the other just that they're different
one could choose a different terminology
depending on what they were
investigating they could also vary the
number of clusters to calculate so this
highlights the one of the shortcomings
of clustering analysis and possibly the
dsm as a whole because clusters will
always group together regardless if
there's any meaningful insight into a
particular investigation it's merely a
tool for exploration
not really necessarily for an explicit
explanation and this leads me to the
last data mining technique which is
Association rule mining this is a method
for discovering interesting relations
between data points the idea comes from
market basket analysis used to identify
customers that buy which products they
buy together the aim is primarily
focused on frequent co-occurring so
associates among a collection of terms
it's a fairly straightforward simple
data mining technique that takes on sort
of the pseudocode structure of effects
then why but it's powerful in its
respect to potentially leading to
interesting discoveries we're an item or
items on the Left will correspond to an
item on the right so in every
introduction of Association rule mining
you'll find the beer in diapers
Association as an example the story goes
people that go to the store to buy milk
and diapers often tend to buy beer at
the same time association rules can
support the finding of patterns across
symptoms as well or symptom
co-occurrences which is done in my
research but this is made possible from
the support of the terminology that's
developed as well as aim one as well
improvements to named entity recognition
that was performed a name to I explored
several use cases with various symptom
groupings to identify correspondence
among symptoms
so this association roll mining is
implemented to explore whether
relationships between symptoms concepts
extracted from st. corpus to which the
previous clustering analysis was applied
could provide insights for generating
novel hypotheses so to extend this use
case further I explored associations
that were generated by umls support what
is shown in this bin diagram is that
among these two terminologies some
associations generated were the same as
well as they generate associations that
were completely different so in this
table is a few examples of sociation
that were found by both symptoms on the
left hand side correspond to symptom on
the right hand side there is some
difference in lift calculations where
lift is a calculation of import of
importance determined by a frequency a
threshold and a confidence probability
one thing to note the overall count of
associations produced by you molest was
much larger than the newly developed
terminology however many of the metrics
were much higher with the PTSD
terminology rules two and three here
interesting as they both includes less
common symptoms that correspond to the
DSM stressor criteria this is
interesting because stressors can really
trigger the disorder and set in motion
the effects of the disorder so finding
all symptoms that can that can point to
it can potentially lead to early
identification of patients that are
exposed to it so finally to demonstrate
a useful example I've gone through all
this work to build the terminology I've
became really good metrics from
implementing it in a pipeline and now
I've got hundreds of associations
between symptom concepts at the
beginning of the talk I expressed
interest in developing applications
to support clinical researchers and
clinicians also pointed out several
deficiencies in the screening process
there is potential in developing
clinical monitoring applications where
one or two symptoms could identify
Canada patients that need to be screened
more thoroughly with a checklist so
using minimal number of symptoms can
potentially create this sort of clinical
alert rather than relying six or seven
from the diagnostic criteria or an
extensive checklist and this could
improve clinical workflow with this sort
of automated process so using a variant
of Swanson's open discovery where
literature-based discovery can identify
a to be relationships and b2c
relationships to explore whether
associations can be acquired from the A
to C relationships and these are often
less than obvious or well known and
these a deceive relationships have been
used in several industries for exploring
new discoveries and generating ideas
Diane I need to wrap it up pretty soon
is that right I can't see the clock back
there okay
so while exploring the association's
that I collected I noticed that many of
the association's gathered where
dissociative concepts explored caw
responded to these dsm stressor concepts
and with good metrics and this is
heavily supported by the literature
where dissociative concept or
dissociative concepts are used to create
risk prediction models also noticeable
is the many symptoms from the DSM
criteria of avoidance that have strong
correspondence to these same
dissociative concepts these avoidance
concepts also had some of the best
recall and precision metrics and the
text mining of limitations so after
lowering the threshold and rerunning the
algorithm it's found that these avoided
symptoms do in fact correspond to the
stressors which could be helpful in this
sort of clinical event monitoring to
identify the candidate patients for more
in-depth screening so when I first began
to collect these these associations and
with all the criticism that the DSM the
diagnostic criteria my mind went
immediately well which one is the most
important and while in this research I
came nowhere even close to answering
this question I did find that many
interesting associations came from the
avoidance symptom clustering and while
browsing these acquired associations
they were not only interests interesting
themselves but in the fact that they
came from PubMed abstracts and I could
only imagine implementing this sort of
technique on a rich document corpus such
as a mental health progress notes so
again while this is just another tool
for exploration it does provide
potential hypothesis that should be
investigated with a more scientific
study so hopefully these few examples
highlight the importance of expanding
terminology research toward developing
reliable biomedical applications there
are opportunities to enhance engineering
of interop
methods to acquire this information from
any electronic or web available resource
the growing rate of information requires
these automatic automated techniques to
allow researchers and clinicians to keep
pace the development of these
domain-specific terminologies
implementation of text mining pipelines
and pattern identification with the data
mining algorithms they provide
opportunities to address this growing
information overload and while this work
of developing terminology is
time-consuming it does provide accurate
concept recognition and automated
annotation this automatic automatic can
also provide the annotation component
for supervised training a more complex
text and data mining algorithms also
note the PTSD terminology it's built
with a top-level ontology
characteristics to support future
enhancements toward the pts do ontology
with this ontology what is hoped is also
could be developed as actionable
knowledge that can be acquired through
semantically annotated and corporate
linked to source terminologies something
that will be important enhancements for
processing capabilities to support
clinical decision support applications
so in closing we as a healthcare
community have been dealing with this
disorder for a really long time and with
relatively minimal success it's my hope
that novel approaches such as this like
making use of the growing domain
narrative text and applying outside of
the box type approaches that we can a
prior acquire proficiencies to acquire
this knowledge and garner meaning from
it and in a way to positively impact
this disorder with that I'd like to
thank each and every one of my committee
members as well as d mice students
faculty and staff also the ontology
development group here the Yom I'm sorry
at ohsu as well as the semantic
knowledge representation group at the
National Library of Medicine like to
give a good thanks to the Department of
Veteran Affairs health care system with
all their support and lastly my training
grant that was made possible by the
National Library of Medicine thank you
what need to remind about touching that
yeah for those who ask questions please
hold down the mic nice presentation back
in your first aim when you looked when
you identified all that new terminology
that was not present in any of the
existing did you do any analysis on on
what type of terms those were I would
imagine I mean you showed a few examples
but that it a lot of the medical term
biomedical terminologies are kind of
disease oriented and symptom common
symptom oriented but so first did you
look yeah the back I think it's not X I
think it's more later on in the talk but
just just the ones that you would when
all the missing ones you define okay so
the questions are did you look at the
yeah that slide the new concepts any
generalizations you can make about the
concepts that you found and is it
possible that they mapped into either
broader concepts or or slightly
different concepts so yes absolutely so
how this research came about was through
my NLM training rotation and my project
to enhance the umls and support of their
application and so in fact a lot of the
concepts do exist but like you're saying
there are more oriented toward diseases
and they they don't meet the context of
PTSD definitions
many of many of those exist but what is
found is the large number of concepts
that are not available so common as I'm
talking as I'm as my goal is to identify
all concepts related to PTSD much of the
building of the process was developed
from annotations that were performed in
an annotation project at the Department
of Veteran Affairs and what is often a
scene is especially in clinical text
providers will type out exactly what the
patient says so for instance of course a
term like hallucination exists in
terminology however patients will say
things like seeing things that aren't
there and so it's my go that that that
this sort of text can link back to the
concept of elucidation so this sort of
information can be shared among among
other applications and specifically as a
lot of new developments in specifically
the area of treatments that come about a
common example was I guess what was it a
lot of new therapies are created that do
not exist at all or are frankly some of
them are illegal now some are so they're
not really defined as a good treatment
but yet yet and also just simple things
like mindfulness that is usually easily
captured in a lot of terminologies as a
concept of something else however
mindfulness is important treatment in
the in the area of post-traumatic stress
disorder yes please you have a question
from the Twitter own okay do you see
potential for these methods to better
define identify patients with the PTSD
disassociate do sometimes yes hopefully
and this is where it has to start it's a
really important question because it
Kelly gets to the heart of what I
ultimately see something like this doing
as I was talking about the DSM there is
a great amount of overlap between other
symptoms and commonly in PTSD patients
their comorbid with other disorders that
share the same symptoms however
treatments are developed specifically to
to impact these post traumatic stress
disorder symptoms so in the long term we
do need to be able to identify all
concepts and differentiate those that
occur from other disorders such as
depression and substance abuse yes sir
alright so i'm trying to think straight
talk by the way really glad they're
strides being made in this area i'm
wondering about the claims about a
terminology being helpful in that named
entity recognition versus it being
helpful in evaluating these kinds of or
helping sort of as sort of a gold
standard for finding those things so did
you tease I think the evaluation used
the PTSD oh is that right for the
evaluation of NER use that correct great
did you try using non so did you try
using alternative types of ontologies or
sort of unsupervised methods for coming
up with and named entity recognition
terms other than PTSD oh so that so that
we can tell whether it was just that
PTSD Oh was the right thing to be
looking for or if it was actually that
using it in looking for the theme health
I think so so there's definitely the the
list of existing terminologies out there
is large in several different types of
structures that that I had represented
in one of the slides so a lot of how the
pts do was developed it acquired
concepts from those existing resources
however unless if there's an annotation
in these existing resources that says
this is a PTSD concept it's going to
have trouble recognizing that as
explicitly the PTSD concept and as
you're asking about unsupervised
technique this sort in a sense this is
really unsupervised other if your other
than being supported by the terminology
in the long run looking at other
automated techniques this would provide
the supervised training of supporting
these more complex evaluations so for
instance running this text mind text
mining pipeline supported with this pts
do or any other domain specific
terminology it could annotate the corpus
in order to train these days
unsupervised based machine learning type
algorithms I think that's what you're
kind of asking is that is that sort of
so yes so that sort of gets into the
little bit of debate about developing of
this focus develop devoting so much time
and energy of focusing on the
terminology because yes a lot of this
this sort of entity identification can
be developed with other types of tools
with other types of machine learning
algorithms and wouldn't require this
advanced terminology and could make use
of those existing terminologies however
my my argument in favor of this is too
rather than then putting a lot of this
metadata in the code as comments a lot
of this can be stored within the
terminology itself something that will
be really important as this terminology
is able to evolve as PTSD is better
understood and new treatments come
available so ultimately I see a
combination of both if we're going to
achieve the necessary accuracy that's
going to allow clinicians to make
decisions based upon these sort of tools
acquiring information from narrative
text I think it's going to require both
developing these very advanced well
covered terminologies but also focusing
on the supervised unsupervised type of
learning machine learning algorithms
native
so specifically concept that need to be
acquired or concepts that were acquired
from one of the systems yeah definitely
so there's again developing the
terminology depending on your intended
use case are you wanting a higher
sensitivity or specificity my go is to
build the all-inclusive the capture of
terms so yes there's a lot a lot of
words depending on the corporates that
you're looking at I mean of course this
sort of work is a lot easier on medical
literature published literature the
terms are more defined and less vague a
lot of higher-level concepts however
it's tricky when you start looking at
the patient records like some of the
like the examples that I gave a lot more
abbreviations a lot more vagueness and
the terms that are used in the clinical
text and also one thing that I didn't
cover a potential future application or
source of more terminology is on web
forums acquiring those because because
they the extreme of the vagueness of a
concept they use their it's very great
all right thank you